vous connaissiez les critiques de cinéma
les critiques de théâtre il y a aussi
les critiques de l'actualité c'est
l'équipe merveilleuse de Paf que je vous
présenterai tout à l'heure avec au
sommaire aujourd'hui on parlera des
élections régionales avec la candidature
de Valérie Pécresse qui semble faire
l'unanimité à droite enfin peut-être pas
pour tout le monde ouvert les propos
notamment de Pierre Bédier à son sujet
on parlera aussi de politique avec ce
qui se passe au Front national mais
aussi ce qui se passe à l'UMP est-ce que
c'est déjà gagné pour Nicolas Sarkozy
l'alliance entre Martine Aubry et
François Hollande pour le congrès du
Parti socialiste et puis on parlera
aussi d'éducation avec la réforme des
collèges qui semble mécontenter à peu
près tout le monde et de tourisme avec
avec une réforme dont on parlera
notamment avec Jean-Luc Madec celle du
fait maison et puis il y aura beaucoup
d'autres sujets qu'on abordera au cours
de cette émission et pour les aborder je
vous présente Stéphane Monson bonjour
de la faculté de droit de Versailles
Saint-Quentin est toujours enseignant et
quoi ça à la Faculté cette même faculté
droite Florence perca des choqué bonjour
vous êtes toujours aux avocate
la prochaine Jean-Luc comme Jean-Luc
Madec qui était tout templier avocat des
Templiers
le seul restaurateur qui renverse la
table de temps en temps
alors il y a la jeunesse qui
représentait avec Antoine moulin bonjour
ça va bien bonjour se porte bien oui je
porte bien là on sort le prochain numéro
la semaine prochaine il s'appelle le
complément le compte journal d'actualité
locale de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
alentours absolument Sephora Melli vous
êtes aussi à l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin mais vous n'en saignez pas
comme comme Stéphane vous vous êtes
encore étudiant et oui je continue à
apprendre il faut il faudrait que le
début de la vieille c'est lorsque
justement on arrête d'apprendre donc
continuer à apprendre dans cette
émission notamment avec Jean-charles
lajouadi qui est éditeur comme le dit
aussi la dernière fois il y a pas
vraiment
alors je propose de commencer avec les
élections régionales qui s'approchent et
notamment en Île-de-France on a une
situation qui paraît à peu près claire à
droite avec la candidature de Valérie
Pécresse qui paraît plus compliqué à
gauche puisqu'il y aura des primaires
entre Jean pollution qui veut un
quatrième mandat et
Marie-Pierre de la Gontrie qui est la
première vice-présidente de la Région
qui se contre contre lui pour les
primaires qu'est-ce que vous pensez
d'abord de la candidature de Valérie
Pécresse peut-être qui veut commencer
personne
politique la plus charismatique du monde
ça c'est quand même
à mon avis évident et puisque j'ai
trouvé curieux c'est sa réflexion sur
Hillary Clinton ce que je sais plus qui
lui a dit est-ce que Hillary Clinton est
un modèle elle dit non là encore rien
prouvé encore rien fait
vu depuis Valérie Pécresse c'est assez
marrant comme réflexion mais voilà mais
sinon effectivement pourquoi pas elle
enfin les propos de Pierre bélier qui
sont cités dans le point
Pécresse n'a pas de Pif
pas de charisme si la politique sur le
terrain s'apprenait à l'école elle
serait la meilleure mais ça ne s'apprend
pas pour gouverner une région il ne faut
pas seulement connaître ces dossiers
de la même partie s'apprécier beaucoup
c'est tout à fait d'ailleurs
leçons a donné à Madame Pécresse mais en
tout cas moi qui ai eu l'occasion
d'approcher madame Pécresse de près je
peux vous assurer que c'est une
personnalité un parfaitement compétente
et qui a une connaissance des rouages
politiques comme rarement j'ai vu et
alors elle a l'air de dire que cela dit
rien sécurité elle a fallu toujours
qu'elle fasse preuve même auprès de
Sarkozy enfin clairement oui on lui a
pas fait de cadeau
le fait que ça soit une femme Florence
par exemple
que des femmes puissent aller à des
postes importants on avait vu
dernièrement sur les départementales à
quel point il y avait de la parité et
finalement l'infini très peu de femmes
présidentes
très peu 7 sur combien donc moi je
trouve que c'est une bonne chose qui est
une femme qui puisse accéder à cette à
cette situation je suis aussi très
étonné de sa remarque sur Hillary
Clinton parce que je pense que c'est
quand même
4 ans à tête du ministère des Affaires
étrangères 8 ans sénateur d'état de New
York enfin je pense que un petit peu
d'expérience quand même
on peut dire une connerie en sortant
d'un match de foot comment sortant d'un
ring politique c'est pas grave c'est pas
très on va pas non plus lui en tenir
c'est quelqu'un je trouve que c'est une
femme qui est extrêmement brillante qui
connaît bien ses dossiers et je trouve
que c'est un peu gonflé de devenir lui
faire le reproche d'être une femme qui
connaissait dossiers justement il y a
souvent comme ça des gens c'est
quelqu'un de très brillant qui avait des
études universitaires très bien qui a
fait je sais qui a fait les dates
universitaire
des grandes écoles pardon plutôt que je
crois que cela lui a été pardonné mais
vous avez raison et souvent ces gens-là
ont parfois du mal à se faire accepter
aux politiques oui oui enfin moi je je
j'oserais vous dire que je enfin à titre
à titre presque affectif si vous voulez
je préférais Valérie Pécresse au Conseil
d'État j'avais grand plaisir à la lire
c'était une elle a été commissaire du
gouvernement on appelle maintenant
rapporteur public absolument brillante
elle est à l'origine de de d'évolution
juridique qui sont tout à fait
primordiales et alors c'est vrai que de
la part de Pierre Bédier c'est un peu
sans doute un peu cru mais enfin la vie
politique est ainsi faite mais je
comprends un peu bon voilà HEC n'a et
puis il y en a peut-être d'autres
université par exemple
vaste sujet je suis pas sûr qu'un
ministre des université soit vraiment
utile il y en a pas vraiment en ce
moment et ça et ça continue j'allais
dire à fonctionner ou plutôt à ne pas
fonctionner mais non voilà c'est vrai
que son charisme je l'ai entendu une
fois une espèce de rassemblement comme
cela bon il y a peut-être un peu de
métier encore à apprendre mais mais cela
dit c'est vrai que bon pierre bédiat
parcours complètement différent
de la base en fait voilà c'est vrai
qu'on a envie Valérie Pécresse se lâche
un jour elle ouvre les vannes et que
c'est ce qu'on dit un peu de Fillon
aussi on est valable de la véritable
personnalité de Valérie Pécresse qui est
sûrement plus rigolote que qu'elle ne le
laisse paraître qui a discuter de tas de
choses de vraiment intéressantes mais là
elle est trop enfermée
quelqu'un qui la connaît bien qui dit
elle est elle est pas très rigolote mais
Merkel non plus oui
Sephora et Antonin
je trouve que c'est un personnage qui
est assez fédérateur après oui les échos
qu'on peut en avoir en tant que ministre
des universités sont pas forcément à la
hauteur du personnage je crois qu'il y a
eu des petits loupés à ce niveau là mais
je trouve que c'est une réforme assez
courageuse pour le coup sur le ce qu'on
aurait pas pu faire mieux est-ce que ça
n'a pas handicapé quelque part notre
faculté qui on fait des freins encore
aujourd'hui d'une façon d'une autre je
pense que il y a quelque chose mais ça
reste une belle candidature pour
lui-même quoi je partage la vie de
Sephora à mon avis la réforme sur
l'autonomie des universités était une
connerie et pour lui dire recrutement
non non mais vraiment aujourd'hui si
l'université de verset 50 ans en
Yvelines et dans cet état c'est en
partie parce qu'il y a des partenariats
publics privés qui ont pu être mis en
place et l'entreprise de plus en plus
dans dans l'université
on va pas faire un débat sur la réforme
des universités mais sur cette dynamie
elle était quand même réclamée à ses
grandes bon encore je sais pas d'une
part je ne sais pas par qui et d'autre
part l'autonomie si vous voulez au
regard de ce que de de ce qu'on envoie
n'est que n'est qu'un slogan donc un
slogan non soit enfin soit on est
autonome soit on ne l'est pas alors
c'est plutôt l'autonomie pour entre
guillemets pardonnez-moi l'expression
les emmerdements mais en réalité
la tutelle de l'État est toujours aussi
forte alors je
je trouve pas qui est spécial
spécifiquement à s'en plaindre mais
cette autonomie elle est essentiellement
d'ordre formel
surtout que ça va mieux aujourd'hui mais
en réalité on perd quand même bon nombre
de
cure la faculté de l'être moderne n'est
plus qu'elle n'est plus qu'elle était la
peur du son niveau elle a perdu ses
professeurs elle a perdu ses filières si
vous regardez que ce soit en sciences
politiques de la même façon il y a une
forme de refonte qui se fait
qui est dommageable et préjudiciable à
la facultés
de Versailles Saint-Quentin je pense que
ça va pas si bien que ça et si on prend
le cas de la bibliothèque universitaire
alors là ça va plus du tout il y a
vraiment de gros soucis et ça fait en
droit deux ans qu'on achète plus de
livres parce qu'il y a plus d'argent et
pour autant
c'est un établissement public qui est
mal géré bon un moment donné non
mais les responsables de quelque part
la réforme de la loi d'autonomie c'est
quand même valérité 13 qu'il a mené il y
a un cadre structurel qui pesait par la
loi nationale donc après on peut dire
que Valérie Pécresse elle est pour rien
on est favorable à sa candidature mais
moi je suis pas d'accord je suis pas
d'accord du tout et je pense que la
faculté actuellement elle est vraiment
dans la me semble dans la mouise alors
certes mais quand on voit le nombre de
Master qui ont été supprimés moi j'ai
une amie qui devait faire son master
l'année prochaine à l'uqsq en M2 elle
est venue en M1 exprès pour être à du SQ
au final on lui a dit ciao bye bye bah
il y a plus de M2 donc on fera un jour
peut-être un débat sur l'université mais
mais
c'est plus intéressant
mais je veux dire peut-être qu'on peut
pas faire non plus partout toutes les
diplômes voilà il y a peut-être des
choses aussi à faire il y a peut-être
moins d'un mois de moins de moyens moins
d'argent c'est un vrai débat qu'on peut
avoir mais qu'on n'aura pas le temps
d'avoir aujourd'hui je vous propose
d'ailleurs de voir un sujet sur sur la
candidature de valérubérès comment elle
a lancé sa candidature
une arrivée en musique au milieu d'une
foule de 2000 personnes depuis la scène
Saint-Denis Valérie Pécresse a voulu
marquer les esprits et adresser un
message aux électeurs elle est la seule
à pouvoir battre les socialistes lors
des régionales en Île-de-France
programmée en décembre et ce gâchis
c'est le bilan de la gauche c'est
l'échec du trio Jean-Paul Huchon
Marie-Pierre de la Gontrie son bras
droit depuis tant d'années et de la
verte Emmanuel cosse
tous les Franciliens le disent on vit
moins bien en Île-de-France en 2015
qu'en 1998 cette ferveur me m'encourage
énormément mais vous savez je pense
qu'il y a une envie d'alternance une
envie de changement la région
Île-de-France c'est le moteur de l'avion
France et si nous changeons la région je
j'en ferai à laboratoire de l'alternance
avec moins d'impôts avec plus de
logements plus de transport et puis
aussi plus d'emplois un grand pacte
régional en faveur de la ruralité un
soutien à l’accession sociale ou encore
un plan horsec pour les transports
figure dans ses propositions mais bien
qu'en tête dans les sondages ces
derniers mois l'inconnu Front National
et la présence d'une liste udi pour est
néanmoins hypothéquer la victoire c'est
d'abord une battante la vie est
difficile chacun de ceux qui sont ici le
savent bien dans la vie faut se battre
rien n'est acquis rien n'est donné
soutenu par Nicolas Sarkozy mais aussi
par François Fillon et sur le plan local
par Pierre Bédié président du Conseil
département al qui avait tous fait le
déplacement Valérie Pécresse souhaite
donc une union dès le premier tour avec
l'UDA
de la conviction parce qu'elle est
passionnée de l'Île-de-France parce que
elle a un sens du de l'intérêt général
qui est sain et dont on a besoin ici en
Île-de-France d'ici à l'été l'ancienne
ministre actuel député en tant parcourir
les 100 circonscription de
l'Île-de-France
alors est-ce que une autre femme face à
Valérie Pécresse c'est ce qu'on saura
après la primaire qui oppose Jean-Paul
Huchon et Marie-Pierre de la Gontrie qui
est la première vice-président de la
Région
champion quatrième mandat très bien pas
bien il faut s'arrêter un moment
il faudrait mieux limiter le cumul des
mandats dans le temps que dans le nombre
c'est-à-dire que ça me dérange pas qu'un
type soit député maire conseiller
régional conseiller général etc mais
mais pas pendant 50 ans c'est ça qui est
ridicule
je pense qu'il faut limiter les mandats
tout le temps et dans toutes les
dimensions c'est à dire matériellement
et et temporellement quatre mandats on
va dire que ça suffit peut-être en tout
cas voilà enfin avec ces candidats il y
a enfin il y a presque photo pour le
plus charismatique
le plus charismatique qui soit lui non
plus on sait jamais remis de la perte du
roi Louis XVI à qui on a coupé la tête
et
notre pays est incroyable c'est à dire
que en marquer dès Napoléon Bonaparte
devenu Napoléon 1er on a cessé de
remettre en place des aristocraties
monsieur Huchon et finalement le
représentant le plus sympathique
peut-être mais en tout cas dans la durée
est trop longue maintenant de cet
aristocratie qu'il faut mettre dehors
mais vous avez pas peur de dire au fond
on cherche comme ça toujours des gens
charismatiques des génétiques alors que
peut-être qu'on pourrait chercher des
gens compétents ça serait pas mal ce
serait bien
le tour trop long mandat ou pas
c'est beaucoup trop moi je suis pas une
limitation à un mandat encore maximum
à mon avis si les élus savent travailler
en équipe il y a pas besoin de faire
demande l'équipe c'est à les
connaissances pour mener un mandat avec
une autre personne
quand quelqu'un n'est pas éligible il
perd le pouvoir 2 ans avant les les
élections d'après
sur quel sujet vous pensez que ça va se
jouer il y a les c'est quoi les sujets
importants de transport évidemment c'est
toujours ça c'est toujours le transport
toujours ça pour les premiers discours
qu'on entend c'est plus de transport
plus de logements et moins d'impôts
faudra un peu qu'on m'explique mais et
puis plus d'emploi elle passe Navigo
aussi qui occupe beaucoup
là qui qui c'est vrai qu'on investit
beaucoup sur des grands transports et
des futurologues qui disent mais c'est
un peu idiot parce que plus ça va aller
plus grâce à l'informatique on va rester
plutôt chez soi on va avoir moins besoin
de se transporter donc est-ce qu'on est
pas en train de faire des des transports
qui coûtent qui coûtent d'un argent fou
et qui ne serviront peut-être plus dans
10 ans ou dans 15 ans puisque il faut
toujours raisonner à 15 ans ou 20 ans de
oui mais on ira toujours avoir des
matchs de foot au Stade de France on ira
toujours non mais il y a toujours fait
ses courses on ira toujours non il y
aura toujours besoin un transport de
toute façon effectivement très jusqu'au
dites pas forcément pour aller bosser
tous les jours au même endroit mais mais
effectivement après moi je voterai les
yeux fermés pour le candidat qui au-delà
de l'amélioration des du rythme des
transports ferait en sorte que on puisse
prendre le métro il y a un truc sur le
le harcèlement et qui avait des
frotteurs dans le métro
se faire frotter mais en fait moi
j'espère je prends rarement le métro
mais quand je m'assois dans le métro
c'est impossible d'être en face de
quelqu'un sans avoir les cuisses
entremêlés les types qui ont conçu ça et
on accepte ça on accepte on accepte de
voyager dans des conditions mais nos
heures de pointe c'est c'est pas
possible donc c'est ça le vrai scandale
tout à fait d'accord en fait
non non mais ceci dit c'est vrai que la
question de transport en commun est
cruciale aujourd'hui on a des pics de
pollution régulièrement et si on
améliore pas la condition de transport
des voyageurs sur les lignes de
transport en commun on va jamais régler
les problèmes de pic de pollution non
plus donc je pense qu'il faut injecter
de l'argent dans dans tout ce qui touche
au transport de en commun et surtout
privilégié le transport à 10 km 15 km
pour aussi privilégier l'économie locale
parce qu'il faut aussi réfléchir à ça
c'est-à-dire comment on fait pour éviter
de dépenser trop d'énergie voilà alors
peut-être passer un autre sujet on
devient fragile quand on prend de l'âge
genre dormais sans rentrer à la Pléiade
et aussi à l'hôpital en même temps et
Jean-Marie Le Pen qui est un conflit
avec sa fille qui rentre aussi à
l'hôpital c'est plutôt du deuxième que
je voulais parler de la famille Le Pen
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de cette colle
je crois que Jean-Luc vous pensez que
tout ça c'est une fausse quand même oui
mais en même temps pardon mais ça me
gêne
cette marque Le Pen alors bon
ces gens autour d'eux des communicants
et des spécialistes de haut vol et bon
voilà j'ai déjà dit que vivement c'était
du grand théâtre sinon du Grand Guignol
pardon mais voilà c'est tout c'est pas
plus à dire sur cette marque là
bon donc vous pensez qu'ils sont
d'accord et qu'ils se répartissent
d'accord du tout il y a différents clans
au Front national il y a des gens et
encore une fois il y a rien de commun
entre Gaulle Nice et
Philippot c'est pas du tout le même
formidable non mais c'est pas la même
formation il ne pense que les chevaux
ils ne pensent pas la même chose l'un et
l'autre ils n'ont pas été formés de la
même façon ils n'ont pas les mêmes
objectifs dans la vie non pas la même
vie privée ils n'ont pas le poste ils
sont ils sont à l'opposé donc c'est trop
facile de mettre toujours le Front
national dans le même sac en disant
c'est c'est juste des des abrutis non
c'est un peu plus compliqué que ça et
c'est pas en les traitant
systématiquement d'abruti et en disant
qu'ils sont tous pareils que on pourra
effectivement lutter contre leur
impressions qu'on peut avoir que au fond
marine Le Pen gagne à cette querelle
puisque ça permet de crever une sorte
d'abcès qui qui était difficile
pour l'instant oui forcément il y a des
politique fondamentale qui sont en cause
là-dedans c'est-à-dire que le Front
national version Jean-Marie c'est un
parti un parti protestataire qui n'a
absolument jamais eu vocation à
gouverner à exercer les responsabilités
et on dit que le Pen était horrifié au
soir du
d'une à 2002 en avril
parce que non non évidemment pas ce
qu'il voulait en revanche la ligne la
ligne marine elle affiche une sinon une
vocation du moins une volonté assez
forte de devenir un parti de
gouvernement lorsqu'il est très
compliqué parce que quand on veut être
parti du gouvernement il est difficile
de rester parti
tout seul d'une part ça va pas être
possible mais de surcroît il va falloir
changer de ligne assez clairement c'est
ce qui se produit depuis que Marine est
aux responsabilité c'est pour ça que
c'est le début peut-être d'un changement
de ligne d'un rapprochement c'est une
confirmation ou du moins un accélérateur
de changement de ligne Florence je vais
pas rajouter grand chose parce que je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec ce qui
vient d'être dit je pense ils sont ils
sont tout à fait différents sur la ligne
politique et peut-être ils ont des
outrances
équivalentes mais dans des domaines
différents et je suis pas du tout
d'accord avec avec
quelqu'un qu'on parle de marque FN et
c'est tout à fait ça c'est à dire que à
mon avis la famille Le Pen met en scène
les courants idéologiques qui traversent
le parti il y a des cours en
idéologiques différents mais au final ça
servira le même clan
ça servira oui peut-être observer leur
temps d'antenne quoi c'est incroyable
par rapport à ce qu'ils sont non parce
que
derrière tout ça il y a quand même il y
a quand même un côté absolument
romanesque absolument incroyable
non non on est en France quand même le
on est fort quand même entre François
Hollande Ségolène Royal etc la famille
de paix il y a des dimensions
romanesques au-delà de la politique qui
sont qui sont assez passionnantes et qui
qui intéresse forcément un peu les gens
pardon c'est vrai moi je pense c'est
c'est l'heure de gloire en ce moment de
Marine Le Pen
c'est la confirmation en tout cas mais
j'ai peur parce que si on regarde bien
en très peu de temps on a beaucoup
beaucoup parlé de Marion maréchal Le Pen
il y a un gros gros coup de projecteur
qui est mis sur ce personnage qui ne
suit pas forcément qui ne s'inscrit pas
dans le courant de sa tante qui elle
préfère qui est plus conservatrice comme
son comme ça
si on l'écoute attentivement et j'ai
enfin j'ai peur non j'ai pas peur mais
je pense que Marine d'ici peu va se
faire quelque parcours circuités par
Marion qui est soutenu par son
grand-père la preuve en est il s'est
retiré de il s'est retiré de la région
PACA il se présentera pas pour les
régionales il laisse la place à sa
petite fille donc je pense qu'elle est
elle est fortement soutenue par son
grand-père il est si peu il risque d'y
avoir un nouveau clash Mario marine on
verra
la situation à droite avec Nicolas
Sarkozy qui annonce que l'alternance est
en marche puis
qui considère que qui considère que le
primaire c'est déjà joué que de toute
façon les doigts dans le nez et que
Fillon et Juppé sont déjà morts
qui s'est trouvé qu'il a trouvé les
républicains et le changement de mort
évidemment parce que d'abord je trouve
ça tellement amusant parce que
d'entendre tous les gens on va dire
maintenant on va faire un fond
républicain là ils vont quand même être
un petit peu emmerdés
cela dit tout le monde dit oui le
grimpeur a pas le droit d'être de
s'appeler les républicains je veux dire
les gens de droite sont probablement
beaucoup plus républicains que les
socialistes ne sont socialistes et ils
sont quand même ils appellent le Parti
socialiste donc chacun à peu près hanté
une marque et puis voilà c'est tout il
fallait penser avant c'est intéressant
c'est que votre contrôle mais le mot
républicain en France est plutôt de
gauche et la connotation
la connotation qui vient qui vient avec
aux États-Unis et plutôt de droite ça
vous savez c'est comme comme le terme ou
la notion de laïcité chacun a sa propre
œil exception c'était effectivement le
républicain aux États-Unis ça n'a rien à
voir
républicain plutôt de gauche au 19e
siècle oui c'était prévu enfin voilà
aujourd'hui bah non justement c'est
c'est une espèce de de alors il y a le
catch all party le parti attrape tout le
monde c'est vraiment le nom attrape tout
et vous savez que aujourd'hui le nom
d'un parti politique c'est ce qu'on
appelle du branding c'est-à-dire une
réflexion sur les marques et ce sont des
spécialistes de marque commerciale qui
réfléchissent au nom des partis
politiques alors ce qui en dit long
aussi sur le corpus et l'épaisseur de
l'étoffe idéologique et philosophique si
j'ose dire qu'il y a derrière c'est à
dire il y a souvent du vide et que ces
marques commerciales sont là pour
masquer un vide sidéral et finalement
très important alors il a raison
républicain ça veut dire quelque chose
quand même
se réclame au temps de la République
tu diras à part les monarchistes
au niveau ça comme parce que je pense
que c'est pas neutre d'avoir utilisé le
mot de républicain pour essayer de
monter une barrière contre le FN et
rejeter le FN dans l'illégitimité et en
disant on est des républicains essayer
de monter symboliquement diriger cette
barrière avec le Front national
du 9 janvier un retour à la république
un retour à l'ordre public des valeurs
très fortes démocrate
c'est à dire une américaineisation
politique française non mais pourquoi
pas en tout cas on en aura fini avec le
l'UMPS ça sera terminé donc ça c'est
déjà pas mal retrouver autre chose
sur un point c'est que l'alternance est
en marche mais on parle aujourd'hui
alors je sais pas si le quinquennat est
pour beaucoup mais il a sûrement une
part de responsabilité là-dedans on
parle de l'ultra alternance c'est-à-dire
que une alternance qui qui se déroule à
un rythme effréné dire qu'on peut dire
que dès le lendemain du second tour de
l'élection présidentielle ça y est le
balancier repart dans l'autre sens
regardez ce qui s'est passé après
l'élection de Sarkozy en 2007 Sarkozy a
systémique lui et les siens ont
systématiquement perdu toutes les
élections intermédiaires ce qui se passe
pour Londres c'est la même chose et en
général ça annonce en effet une
alternance donc se balancier n'est pas
loin de devenir fou avec derrière aux
avant-postes
parler du jeu des sept familles tout à
l'heure papi fifille et petite fille qui
sont là pas loin
on parle de Marc on parle de marketing
politique en réalité on voit bien que
aujourd'hui il y a plus de mots que
d'idées et je crois que c'est un
problème que la société devra régler
rapidement non mais faut pas exagérer
non plus toujours tout critiquer un nom
il en faut bien un donc on va pas on va
pas se fusquer ils ont trouvé un nom
c'est une horreur c'est une marque etc
il faut bien si si le MP ne changeait
pas de nous s'il y avait pas de nom à
l'UMP ou Parti socialiste on serait les
premiers à dire comment les appeler
enfin c'est normal qu'on ait un nom que
vous avez un nom on a tous un nom
pourquoi les pourquoi à droite qui
pourrait ne pas avoir un nom
un programme politique qui tienne la
route avec des hommes politiques qui
tiennent la route plutôt qu'un nouveau
nom mais l'UMP ils ont un nom il
s'appelle
la rupture sur quoi en fait sur le au
niveau du nom à mon avis c'est plus
politique qu'autre chose c'est à dire il
me semble heureusement
non mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
il a Sarkozy a un déficit sur son sur le
centre droit et je pense que les
républicains c'est une façon de de
réancrire
son son ancrage au centre droit
un parti sous Giscard moi j'étais trop
jeune j'étais pas né mais qui s'appelait
les Républicains indépendants
donc c'est une façon de revenir au
centre même vu les indépendants des
paysans
et plus personne ne veut s'appeler à
dépendre les paysans aujourd'hui je ne
sais pas pour le CMI national
vous voulez dire un mot de de l'accord
Aubry Hollande ou on passe dessus très
intéressant
je crois que les
moi ça me surprend toujours mais il y a
des gens qui soutiennent Aubry et il y a
encore un clan où il visiblement donc ça
pour moi c'est une curiosité mais ils
existent ils sont hyper déçus je crois
parce que ils attendaient à ce qu'elle
aille un peu aux classes
de d'une plus grande fragilisation du
psaume on est bien d'accord mais elle
veut pas marquer le seau définitif de
cette fragilisation en même temps là
avec avec cette motion on va le s'il a
avalé ça crée des sacrés couleurs quand
même on l'acceptant parce que quand on
reprend la motion c'est une critique
assez sévère de tout ce qu'il mène en
terme de politique
on peut faire confiance
les accords qu'on fait dans la nuit
voilà il faut lui il faut l'unité
j'espère parce que là ça veut dire sinon
il fait plus rien
d'ailleurs je vous garantis que rien ne
changera et lui il est droit dans ses
bottes comme notre ami
la réforme des collèges parce que
visiblement ça ne satisfait personne
alors il y avait eu l'abandon du
pratiquement l'abandon du grec et du
lapin
il y a quelques semaines sur lesquels
sur lesquels il y a eu déjà beaucoup de
débats cette semaine on a appris la
bandeau de filières européennes
c'est-à-dire les filières comme
Fontainebleau on apprend des langues de
manière assez forte notamment les autres
langues que l'anglais c'est à dire
l'allemand et le russe au prétexte que
voilà c'est lycées seraient ou ces
collèges serait élitiste ces femmes
enfin moi je moi je me cramponne parce
que ça me fait bouillir je suis enfin je
suis outré scandalisé il y a tellement
de trucs qui m'échappent dans ce dans ce
non argument j'y vois un dogmatisme une
espèce de dogmatisme puant derrière tout
cela ce qui c'est de réduire à chaque
fois comme une peau de chagrin les
programmes d'enseignement fondamentaux
et donc de renvoyer vers les cours
privés payants les plus ceux qui peuvent
se développer
suivant
la suppression du grec et du latin alors
les gens se disent mais ça sert à quoi
le grec elle l'atteint aujourd'hui c'est
pas avec ça qu'on va donner des emplois
à nos chers petits mais il y a enfin il
faut il faut réfléchir un peu plus me
semble-t-il j'ai été très marqué par la
lecture d'un bouquin que j'ai lu il y a
quelques mois d'un collègue italien qui
s'appelle Lucio ordinée et son bouquin
s'appelle l'utilité de l'inutile et en
gros il est pas le premier à démontrer
ça
c'était la deuxième édition qui est
parue il y a pas longtemps Jean-Charles
non pas chez toi mais
vraiment et donc en gros il reprend un
discours qui est assez finalement assez
classique mais au terme duquel il dit il
faut vérifier de cette classification
entre savoir
utile voire utilitaire d'un côté et
savoir estampillé inutile pourquoi
est-ce que le grec et le latin
finalement c'est utile alors ne parlons
pas des langues étrangères de toute
évidence au-delà de savoir de poudre
d'être en capacité de lire les auteurs
classiques dans le texte je pense pas
que ce soit là l'utilité fondamentale ça
contraint l'esprit humain et l'esprit de
du jeune du jeune élève du jeune
apprenti a résonné autrement parce qu'en
gros ordiné dit je pense comme je parle
penser c'est se parler à soi-même et
parler de manière différente selon un
ordre différent selon une structure
linguistique différente c'est s'habituer
à avoir une souplesse d'esprit avoir du
recul sur les choses c'est opérer un
recul pour mieux revenir sur des choses
dites essentielles donc tous ces savoirs
qui sont aujourd'hui complètement
fichu à la poubelle à la périphérie
estampillée savoir classique démodé qui
ne servent à rien je crois que c'est une
une erreur mais absolument fondamentale
on avait parlé il y a quelques années du
fait de savoir si on allait pas faire
passer le permis de conduire au lycéen à
l'université il faut maintenant faire
passer des tests pour leur pour
soi-disant à prendre aux étudiants à
aller sur Internet ou à servir d'un
clavier numérique etc enfin
le permis de conduire à l'université
aussi
alors il y a derrière ça aussi et c'est
ce que c'est ce qui me fait bouillir une
espèce de
détox un peu idéologique que je parviens
mal à identifier ça serait un savoir
élitiste mais qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un
savoir élitiste justement dans une
république il y a pas de savoir élitiste
comme vous disiez ça favorise plutôt
enfin les gens favorisés ils s'en fiche
ils peuvent maintenant
donc derrière ça moi je trouve qu'il y a
des arguments enfin qui sont extrêmement
critiquables est-ce que quelqu'un est
opposé à ce discours
Antonin ce qui est très très important
dans ce que dit Stéphane c'est que
finalement on est dans deux philosophies
et ça ce sont des choix politiques
lourds le premier c'est ce qui se passe
c'est à dire qu'on tire vers le bas
l'ensemble de la société et ça provoque
ce que nous vivons au quotidien le
déclin
ou au contraire essayer d'enrichir la
société et ses membres jeune femme jeune
garçon parle le savoir les langues
étrangères mais aussi l'histoire et la
géographie qu'on a quasiment supérieur
depuis déjà une décennie donc on se rend
compte que ce sont deux options
politiques divergentes et il va falloir
que la société décide de son sort où
nous continuons d'aller vers le déclin
ou au contraire nous faisons la
promotion de la culture moi j'insiste
beaucoup là-dessus de l'éducation et de
la transmission du savoir pour faire
demain avec nos enfants une société
performante
d'un abandon tout à fait réfléchi d'une
certaine éducation parce qu'on est les
hommes politiques qui ont pris ces
décisions sont parfaitement au courant
que les les élites et les enfants des
élites de toute façon continueront à
s'intéresser aux humanités elle
s'intéressait ils auront toujours une
éducation quasi parfaite etc et qu'en
revanche pour le pour le pour le peuple
on va faire des écoles de et qui vont
formera directement des chaudronniers on
fabrique la direction
j'espère que les collèges je voulais
lisser vous avez passé des bacs dans des
lycées publics des bacs européens donc
ça va être supprimé il y a des filières
des lycées en milieu rural où on peut
faire des bacs européens maintenant on
va supprimer tout ça donc on va avoir
des inégalités
soient tous égaux et
dans la réalité
je pense que c'est le constat très clair
qu'ils ne sont pas en capacité de faire
en sorte que parce que c'est un
nivellement par le bas ça on est bien
d'accord c'est dramatique même en tant
qu'étudiante moi je sais que je suis
vraiment révolté par ça parce que le
latin ça nous paraît pas moi j'en ai
fait pendant des années des années c'est
un capital précieux comme disait
Stéphane ça permet
un exercice à la réflexion au
raisonnement ça sert en maths le latin
se sert en maths enfin c'est c'est tout
à fait ça et justement c'est c'est le
constat concret on n'a pas les moyens de
faire en sorte que les gens en
difficulté puissent atteindre un niveau
scolaire valable alors ce qu'on va faire
c'est qu'on va niveler tout le monde par
le bas comme ça il y aura plus
d'inégalité tout le monde sera mauvais
c'est dramatique
que vous n'avez pas c'est le livre
Walter qui est une linguiste qui
s'appelle mordicus qui est qui explique
pourquoi le latin nous sert tous les
jours et que même en anglais il y a des
mots enfin le corpus etc qu'on emploie
en anglais ça nous sert même pour
reprendre des lots qui ne sont pas
dérivés directement du latin et en
orthographe évidemment il est faute
d'orthographe qu'on voit aujourd'hui
beaucoup malheureusement je pense que
c'est des enfants étudie le matin le
grec sur la compréhension d'un nombre
absolument incroyable enfin nous aussi
c'est une évidence
alors la France est le premier
destination touristique au monde donc on
peut s'en féliciter c'est très bien même
s'il faudra améliorer sans doute des
choses mais il y a quelque chose sur
lequel je voulais vous entendre Jean
-Luc c'était la réforme du fait maison
c'est vrai que le fait maison jusqu'à
présent c'était pas très très clair
puisqu'on pouvait avoir un peu de
surgelés si on mettait un peu de sel
dessus ça devait du fait maison vous me
regardez si je me trompe là on va régler
une fiction plus simple qui me paraît
important on déclare 85 millions
touristes en France qui nous place comme
étant le premier pays au monde pour
l'accueil des touristes c'est faux ah
bon
sur Internet au moment où vous souhaitez
vous faites tourisme en France 2014 et
vous allez regarder toujours là ce qu'il
en est oui nous avons accueilli 85
millions de touristes en France en 2014
sauf que 20 millions n'ont fait que dit
passé il passe du Nord vers le Sud ou du
Sud vers le Nord
les comptabilisent dans le nombre de
touristes français
le deuxième point c'est qu'il faut
regarder le revenu par touriste et là
nous sommes loin derrière les Espagnols
nous sommes derrière les Italiens
c'est que quand un Allemand à hollandais
un Danois un suédois va en Espagne il y
reste et il est dépense son argent chez
nous il ne fait que passer donc il faut
pas comparer seulement le nombre de
passages de touristes en France il faut
aussi comparer le revenu
et là nous sommes loin derrière nos
compatriotes
directement
ce chiffre qui nous fait enfin qui fait
d'ailleurs nos dirigeants se vantaient
de la position de la France dans le
domaine touristique est un chiffre faux
et à un moment donné il faut quand même
que nos compatriotes sachent que nous ne
sommes pas les premiers au tourisme et
que nous devrions faire beaucoup
d'efforts en termes de qualité d'accueil
de qualité
d'infrastructures pour faire en sorte
que les touristes qui viennent en France
ils restent plus longtemps et il dépense
plus d'argent alors quelle était
l'accueil déjà sur la partie hébergement
il y a beaucoup d'efforts à faire et sur
la partie de la Restauration il y a le
fait maison alors il faut quand même
savoir que la France est un des pays où
il y a le plus grand nombre de
restaurants et les choses on la France
c'est 100 000 restaurateurs qui
aujourd'hui servent leurs clients à
table c'est pas rien quand même le fait
maison concerne moins de 5000 d'entre
eux
95.000 restera heure servant le client à
table ne sont pas concernés
par le fait maison alors il y a une
modification dans le nouveau décret qui
vient de paraître elle est vraiment
toute petite c'est que il était au
préalable écrit que nous devions servir
les produits faits maison à base de
produits bruts aujourd'hui on dit à base
de produits crus ce qui change rien mais
dans la cervelle d'un certain nombre de
journalistes ils ont cru que le cru ça
voulait dire pas surgelé en fait pas du
tout nous restons avec des produits
bruts simplement il ne doivent pas avoir
été précuises ou pochées ou blanchies
c'est tout mais un poisson surgelé
reste un produit cru qui rentre dans le
fait maison
surgeler soi-même un produit est une
idiotie
surgelé sur les bateaux que de s'amuser
à surgeler un produit qui a déjà 3 jours
de marché à Rungis et qui est déjà en
limite de fraîcheur
j'étais vraiment très favorable à l'idée
de ce fait maison pour une raison simple
c'est que il doit y avoir une
différenciation absolument entre le
restaurateur qui a des cuisiniers une
cuisine qui fait rentrer ses produits
bruts surgelés ou pas et qu'il est
transforme dans sa cuisine avec du
personnel et qui donc du coup justifie
du prix de vente sur les sur sa carte de
ces produits contrairement au récepteurs
c'est une minorité oui
contrairement à ceux qui font rentrer
des produits semi finissent ou fini et
qu'il les servent après un réchauffement
soit au four vapeur four micro-ondes ou
font traditionnel cependant cela n'ont
pas à être montré du doigt non plus pour
une raison très très simple c'est que si
vous allez par exemple à Paris
aujourd'hui le prix du foncier est-elle
que les restaurateurs en général ont
tendance à réduire les surfaces de leur
cuisine au profit de l'augmentation des
surfaces de vente des tables et des
chaises à destination de leurs clients
et cela sont amenés évidemment à faire
des économies d'échelle en termes de
production et sont souvent tentés
d'aller faire faire ailleurs les
produits qu'ils présentent à leur carte
pour autant sont-ils des voleurs non les
produits sont-ils de mauvaise qualité
non mais qu'est-ce qu'on leur demande
d'avoir l'honnêteté de dire à leurs
clients le produit que je vous propose à
ma carte à tel prix ce n'est pas moi qui
le fait c'est tellement
alors c'est pas toujours oui voilà mon
cher Stéphane le législateur travaille
avec les organisations professionnelles
dont je fais partie pour précisément
inscrire sur les cartes la totale
transparence sur les produits
dans les restaurants sur la carte aussi
je pense que ce serait pas inutile de le
faire moi ça devient pas c'est cuisine
non mais c'est cuisine de restaurant où
on voit des batteries de 10 20 30
micro-ondes on se dit mais attends mais
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette façon de
faire à manger avec la nationalité
de toute façon le client n'est pas idiot
le client c'est parfaitement ce qui lui
est servi dans son assiette et
aujourd'hui les émissions de télévision
prime time permettent vraiment de faire
la différence entre ce qui est fait
maison et ce qu'il ne l'est pas
cependant c'est pas parce qu'un produit
effet maison qui est bon et ça parce
qu'il est fait à l'extérieur qu'il est
mauvais voilà donc il faut simplement
avertir le client monsieur le client au
prix que je vous vends mon produit je le
fais dans la maison ou monsieur le
client je l'ai acheté dans chez un
fournisseur spécialisé voilà donc on est
très content que quelqu'un qui est un
des représentants professions nous
disent oui il faut plus de transparence
totalement mais dans tout dans tout le
secteurs d'activité d'ailleurs très bien
je voulais peut-être lancer un sujet
parce que c'est intéressant on va parler
un peu d'automobile les gars il y a on
fabrique et à satori des aubépines de
demain enfin en tout cas on y réfléchit
on regarde le fusil puis après on parle
un peu de voiture
cette voiture électrique conduite par
Anne-Charlotte nicou à une particularité
elle peut aussi se conduire sans
chauffeur un véhicule totalement
automatisé bourré de capteurs qui
prennent tout en charge à la place du
conducteur un peu à l'image d'un être
humain la voiture pour conduire a besoin
de percevoir son environnement donc ce
sont les capteurs de perception qui joue
ce rôle là donc celle-ci a une vision à
360 degrés afin de
minimiser le risque d'anglement voire
même supprimer complètement
elle a besoin également de se localiser
donc ce sont le but des capteurs de
localisation puisque vous avez besoin de
savoir où vous êtes et quel est
l'environnement autour de vous et enfin
elle doit prendre des décisions donc ce
qu'on appelle le module de supervision
ce sont toutes l'intelligence embarquée
et tout le cœur de nos algorithmes ce
véhicule prototype est l'une des grandes
fiertés de vdcom il est testé sur les
pistes de satori l'Institut de
transition énergétique a été lancée il y
a un an il travaille sur toutes les
questions de mobilité d'électrification
d'automatisation et de connectivité des
voitures du futur on a les grandes
entreprises de l'automobile française
qui sont fondateurs de vdcom des grands
instituts de recherche et puis également
des PME et bientôt des startups donc
c'est un écosystème de près de 40
membres qui travaillent ensemble tous
les jours
un mariage entre secteur public et privé
entre petites et grandes entreprises
entre chercheurs et ingénieurs qui
portent ces fruits aujourd'hui institut
en poids un peu moins de 100 personnes
ils seront plus de 150 à la fin de
l'année et il est prévu encore une
centaine d'embauches d'ici 2016 pour
fonctionner les décom qui fait partie du
pays le plan d'investissement d'avenir
dispose d'un budget de 19 millions
d'euros ce budget est en croissance donc
sur trois ans et l'ensemble de vdcoms
est financé à 10 ans pour globalement
une centaine de millions d'euros quand
l'État met un les industriels mettent un
ça c'est le principe de base du
financement de vdcom reste une
interrogation à quand une voiture sans
conducteur sur route pour l'heure c'est
interdit en France et en Europe seul
l'état du Nevada aux États-Unis a donné
cette autorisation pour la Google qui a
mais l'avenir s'annoncera Dieu pour
vdcom en octobre prochain la Ville de
Bordeaux va accueillir le Congrès
mondial des systèmes automatisés et les
responsables en sont persuadés les
derniers leviers lég islatifs devraient
se lever en attendant vdcom travail
également sur un pôle d'excellence qui
ouvrira la fin de l'année à sa Tori pour
préparer cette fois les moteurs
électriques de demain
voilà ça c'est les voitures de demain
c'est assez impressionnant d'ailleurs la
seule chose c'est que le ce qu'on
appelait autrefois le plaisir de
conduire de passer les vitesses et tout
ça ça c'est fini Jean-Luc qui dit
que moi je me souviens quand j'étais
gamin il y a donc quelques années
on prenait la route pour faire deux
heures de route on avait quatre accident
quoi aujourd'hui
vous ne voyez plus d'accident sur la
route ou de façon extrêmement rare donc
la route est devenue très sûre et elle
est devenue parce que les conditions à
la fois de conduite la limitation de
vitesse les routes sont devenues
vraiment extrêmement
plus être capable de réparer quoi que ce
soit dans une voiture on va de plus en
plus vers une carte d'autonomie à la
fois de du conducteur et aussi des
mécaniciens qui sont plus capables
aujourd'hui dans les voitures nouvelles
de changer quoi que ce soit et du coup
ça oblige à jeter et donc à gaspiller
des ressources naturelles qui sont
importantes je pense que il faut le
progresse ce serait pas de forcément
quand tu aurais automatiquement mais de
permettre de changer
les pièces enfin de permettre aux
clients aux
personnes qui conduisent de changer des
pièces de leur véhicule facilement
pour toute la consommation le truc le
plus angoissant là-dedans c'est que ces
nouvelles voitures ça fait vomir en fait
oui non non mais c'est sérieux
c'est-à-dire que si on ne regarde plus
la route on a le mal des transports et
on dégueule non mais c'est le véritable
problème de de ces nouveaux trucs c'est
à dire que dans le train on s'est
habitué on regarde le paysage on n'a
jamais été habitué à conduire le train
mais je veux dire qu'on conduise en
voiture qu'on soit le passager passager
on regarde
on a pas le droit d'écouter le portable
d'un prisonnier c'est à dire que c'est
c'est un truc qui moi me rend fou c'est
je peux même pas concevoir le truc c'est
à petit papa en avoir un un portable
mais si on l'écoute c'est illégal de
l'écouter c'est un c'est on est au-delà
de tout quoi comme est-ce que vous avez
pas du fait que il y a la loi et puis il
y a la réalité dans les prisons c'est à
dire qu'il faut aussi laisser un peu
parfois
une laisse un peu plus plus longue au
prisonnier bon après après il y a aussi
des des portables qui sont probablement
confiés aux prisonniers de façon un peu
délibérée parce que si on leur file le
portable quand on a le numéro donc
Laurence
il y a
en détention normalement elle devrait
pas exister ça c'est clair mais c'est
des sujets différents entre le fait
d'avoir un portable et le fait de
pouvoir l'écouter donc c'est vrai que je
comprends que ça se percute un peu dans
la morale mais la loi n'est pas la même
sur ces deux sur ces deux sujets là mais
je pense que le sujet qui a opposé quand
même beaucoup
Christiane Taubira avec le porteur du de
ce projet c'est surtout sur le fait
qu'il souhaite que les les agents
pénitentiaires deviennent des agents de
renseignement au sein même de la prison
et donc cette Taubira y était opposé en
disant mais attention parce que les
agents de la pénitentiaire dépendent du
ministère de la Justice et là il y a le
ministère de l'Intérieur qui met un pied
chez moi ce que je ne veux pas déjà
puisque si on leur donne des fonctions
d'agent de renseignement ils vont plus
dépendre du coup du ministère de la
justice mais ça va être plutôt de
l'Intérieur donc là déjà il y a eu une
zone de frottement entre un Taubira et
ministère d'intérieur et elle a perdu
d'ailleurs puisque c'est passé donc ça a
été voté et
les surveillants ont quand même des
relations très particulières avec les
détenus ils ont des relations de
surveillance mais aussi ils ont des
relations de proximité et voilà ils se
voient tous les jours alors maintenant
si ils deviennent des agents de
renseignement sur ces détenus là ça
risque de poser de sacré problème de
relation sociale à l'intérieur des à
l'intérieur des prisons aussi ils sont
maintenus en interdiction des téléphones
dans les prisons point mais non mais
c'est au-delà de ça parce que il y a des
c'est du renseignement qui va au-delà
des problématiques de téléphone dans la
loi c'est aussi informatique
d'où toutes ces questions sont
importantes enfin mais le plus important
c'est c'est ça reste encore et toujours
l'état dans lequel nous prisons se
trouvent c'est vrai c'est on paye une
incurie et une impéritie de de j'ai pas
50 voir 100 ans d'inaction de la
puissance publique alors c'est vrai que
les prisons ça coûte toujours trop cher
tout le monde s'en fiche et perdument
mais sauf que ce sont des machines et
Cher Maître
des machines qui fabriquent de leur
récidive
donc la conscience a été prise qu'il
fallait prendre la question à bras le
corps mais savent pas tout de suite
voilà un certain temps avant que les
choses soient résolues c'est grâce aux
hommes politiques d'ailleurs que ça
s'améliorer c'est quoi ton a commencé à
mettre les hommes politiques en prison
c'est à dire mais finalement c'est pas
terrible c'est pas c'est pas très connu
obligatoire la présence des avocats dans
la garde à vue à partir du moment où des
gens sont faits parce que
c'est pas 10 minutes donc voilà c'est
pas c'est prison 4 étoiles et les
quartiers VIP
il y a des états dans lesquels les
prisons sont je veux pas dire ouvertes à
la visite de l'extérieur mais pas loin
moi j'ai visité des prisons au Québec
par exemple j'en ai visité en France
mais c'est beaucoup plus compliqué ça
serait pas inutile je trouve que les
citoyens puissent voir ce que c'est que
la prime
le manière français était vraiment
particulier parce que par exemple c'est
impossible pour l'administration
pénitentiaire d'imaginer une prison en
centre-ville ou dans une ville les gens
n'en veulent pas ils sont tous là à dire
faut mettre tout le monde en tôle quand
on leur dit bah ok on met tout le monde
en tôle ou mettons la tôle allume
surtout pas cher
en plein cœur de Paris c'est génial
parce que sa valeur d'exemple je veux
dire tu te balades à Paris tu vois la
prison de la Santé c'est pas un endroit
où tu dis tiens j'aimerais de l'autre
côté les murs non c'est c'est
fait un stage de trois semaines à
Bois-d'Arcy mais j'étais très contente
de rentrer chez moi le soir parce que
claquement de porte toute la journée
difficile il nous reste quelques minutes
peut-être petit tour de table rapide
Sephora il y avait une question sur
laquelle vous vouliez
donc vous vouliez parler un adversaire
qui est pas un anniversaire très gai
anniversaire bring back out Girl qui est
l'enlèvement il y a maintenant un an en
avril dernier de 200 lycéens nigériennes
par Boko Haram et surtout j'aimerais
souligner et m'indigner contre la nonne
intervention de la communauté
internationale par rapport à la
progression de Boko Haram et de daesh
parce que on était tous très affligés le
9 janvier dernier après les attentats de
Charlie Hebdo
la destruction du Patrimoine de
l'Humanité à Mossoul bon ça a pas plus
déclenché des mois à Tunis d'autres
attentats
pour les arrêter alors que je suis à peu
près intimement convaincue que ce soit
l'état d'Israël ou les Américains
pourraient très bien faire quelque chose
de français